i started getting all kinds of questions
from people around the world who were
either wanting to try the high five
habit or had started and had a bunch of
questions
how exactly do i start doing it
the high five habit is a moment every
morning
just for you it has two simple but
powerful steps
number one
standing in front of the mirror just be
with yourself for a second
don't focus on your appearance go deeper
i want you to see the person who's
inside that body the spirit beneath the
skin
the soul behind that face
then
when you feel ready you're gonna high
five yourself in the mirror notice when
you first do it
how your mind goes quiet you might feel
a boost of energy
you might feel a sense of comfort it'll
be okay
you might think i got this
this is a powerful moment without saying
a word you're telling yourself
i love you
i see you
i believe in you let's go
don't rush it
revel in it
this moment
it's for you want to be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
so much more inside you you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best belief
life and learn seven habits that will
change your life
enjoy
habit number two stop holding yourself
back with simon sinek the human brain
cannot comprehend the negative
it is incapable
yes it's true
i'll give you an example
[Music]
okay no no i'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
i'll prove it
i'll prove it okay the human brain
cannot comprehend the negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
you can't tell the human brain not to do
something right and so what happens is
we very often reinforce things
when we put things in the negative
right i can't get apart
i can't get apart
i can't get apart right or
um
i can't do this versus i'm going to keep
doing this
i'm going to keep doing this
i'm going to keep doing this
right
um
and and it's such a huge thing to
convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do with children as
well we're supposed to say instead of
saying to children
don't eat on the couch we're supposed to
say eat at the table
right we tell people what we want them
to do not want them what we don't want
to do pilots know this
right it is well known in the pilot
community that when you tell a pilot
don't hit the obstacle they'll hit the
obstacle
because what they're doing is focusing
on the obstacle
skiers know this
if if you ever seen skiers go through
trees
do you know how they do that it's very
easy it's actually surprisingly easy if
you go through trees on skis and you go
don't hit a tree don't hit a tree don't
hit a tree guess what you're watching
you're only looking at trees
all you're doing is seeing trees you
don't understand how anyone can ski with
all these trees
right
as opposed to follow the snow follow the
path follow the path
the only thing you see is the path
skiers know this
if you say don't hit a tree you'll hit a
tree you won't be able to find a path
because all you see is millions of trees
if you say only follow the path
you actually don't see any trees there's
actually very sparse trees
there's plenty of path there's plenty of
snow
it's the same thing for you if you focus
on the obstacles all you will see is
obstacles if you focus on the path
through the trees
all you will see is path through the
trees
it's your choice how you choose to
perceive your own career it's literally
perspective habit number three reset
your mindset with lisa nichols
so you know when you think about
resetting your mind
we're always committed to moving forward
sometimes prematurely
in order to reset your mind to think
abundantly or to live abundantly you
first have to identify where are you
currently thinking in scarcity
which we don't like to spend any time
there because it's not fun
so and you can't
to me one of the number one ways to
avoid to in a sexy way avoid
transformation is to generalize too much
like oh my life
your life is so big
what areas of your life
are you currently thinking in scarcity
oh in my relationships what part of your
relation there's four different types of
relationships there's romantic there's
family there's colleague and there's
community and what areas
my finances what kind of finances your
income or your outflow your debt
management or your wealth building so
number one the number one you push past
a limiting belief system is that you
identify where it's limited and you it's
almost like going to the doctor saying
doc
my left arm really hurts
he's not just going to start working on
he's going to say where
well you know the upper part well where
in the upper part well over here between
the elbow and the shoulder well where
between it like doctors will ask you so
many detailed questions so that they can
go exactly to where the pain point is
and relieve the pain treat your mindset
that way as well so when you're reaching
for a more abundant way of thinking
start by saying what
frame of thinking what mindset what part
of my mindset what belief system must i
evict to create space let me give you
another example your hand
your hand can only hold on to so much
right so if your hand is already full of
limiting thoughts i'm not good enough
i'll never have wealth money is
difficult to create i'm always going to
be overweight people can't be trusted if
your hand is already full with limiting
beliefs how can you dare hold on to an
abundant way of thinking so first let's
dismantle this truth let's dismantle the
truth that money is hard to make so in
the past i made money hard to make money
is abundant there's enough for all of us
money is simply a tool money is just
dirty paper it's a team member money is
not the end all money gives you access
to better memories okay great let's work
on that and now let's work on i'll
always be broke or whatever the mindset
is right and the reality is no if you
want to have more money coming in or you
want to have more money in your bank
account then keep more than you spend so
how can we do that so you have to be
willing to be mildly to moderately to
significantly inconvenience possibly in
order to keep more than you spend
possibly or you want to grow your top
line and get more revenue you want to
create you might lose a little sleep you
might not be able to go out too many
parties you might not be able to spend
as much on your clothes but you want to
bring in more than you spent so
financial struggle is not imminent
now i'm not saying it's not difficult at
times i've been there
but it's not imminent it's not your
destiny so notice how i can go and i can
dismantle each belief system even if you
don't believe this new truth yet
which i've given you plenty of exercises
around adopting a new mindset you can't
visit a new mindset
you gotta go to a new mindset you gotta
park and you gotta constantly revisit
that mindset called possibility so when
you talk about how do i shift my mindset
to abundant thinking first evict the
negative thinking now that's not an
overnight thing like download it's
evicted there's no sprinkle fairy dust
in this journey there's no magic potion
there's no magic wand this is a ongoing
it's like a muscle it's like your abs
it's like your triceps and your biceps
i've talked about that before you gotta
build that muscle but you first have to
identify what muscle do i want to build
i want to build a belief system around
financial abundance in my life go that
laser i want to build the belief system
around love a healthy love relationship
for me okay then go there energy grows
where energy goes right so what do you
need to know and learn whenever i want
to
take on a new belief system first i
spend time identifying my current
limiting belief system in that area
it's ugly it's uncomfortable i unpack it
then the second thing you do is
identify the results that that limiting
belief system has brought into your life
now that really isn't fun it's funky it
feels like you're sludging to the mud
you start feeling like an idiot you feel
like a nut you're like who am i i'm
brilliant in this area how could i still
be thinking this because you're normal
you're human and humans are full of
imperfections oh and we're managing our
dysfunction that's just that's just who
we are there's no perfect human right so
what does it create in your life what
does it cost you
because i think when you become really
clear of the cost
then you become really clear that you
don't want to pay that cost again i
think we continue to go in the same
circle and end up in the same place
different day different year different
relationship you know different bank
account because we haven't identified
what has this behavior what has this
mindset cost me but when you stop for a
moment ago here's my limiting belief
system and here's what it's cost me
okay i'm done with that
now we can go to an abundant mindset i
think people try to run past those first
two
way too fast and hold on to an abundant
mindset and it doesn't last because they
haven't become clear of the toxic
limiting mindset and its cost so they
slingshot back to that place that they
had started before and end up asking the
question how
did i end up here
again right we've all said that i've
asked that question a little over 100
times right and so i think those are the
first two steps and then
the third thing
is to surround yourself in a tribe of
people
that inspire you to stand on your tippy
toes by the by who they are being
and in order for you to stay in their
proximity
you need to innately grow who you are in
order for you now they don't use it as a
doorway or pathway or rites of passage
but in order for you to feel comfortable
in their presence you got to tip your
toe naturally they even make you nervous
when you're around them i have that i
have a circle of friends who i go
and i've had that circle of friends for
i don't know 15 16 years and i keep
going around them and i always feel
nauseous and they always make me feel
like i want a tippy toe and and they've
they've helped to make me a better woman
they didn't design it they didn't craft
it they didn't tell what to do just
being in their presence and oh by the
way i paid to be in their presence i
consistently pay to be in their presence
i don't have any formal business with
them just being their friends make me
nervous
because they play so big in the world
they serve so big in the world they give
so big in the world they they at a
cellular level they are transformation
like they're the real deal and so i want
to stay in their presence so i maintain
my level of work and so those are the
three things that you do to go from a
limiting belief system mindset to a
mindset of abundance that's the
beginning there are a lot of things in
between but those are the big anchors
that i recommend remember this show is
not a monologue it's not a monologue
it's a dialogue it's a dynamic
conversation between you and i
so that means i would love to hear from
you what's your biggest lesson that you
learned from this particular episode
what was an era in your life you
realized that mindset i need to uplevel
that mindset in that area to go from
scarcity thinking limited thinking to a
thought of abundance a lifestyle in that
particular area also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
habit number four reinvent yourself with
todd herman i say this to people all the
time human beings are not oak trees
an oak tree will always be an oak tree
and acorn will always grow into an oak
tree human beings are not trees we get
to reinvent ourselves at any moment in
time
and you know you could be
living through the narrative in your own
head of a wounded individual because of
stuff that happened to you when you were
young you didn't get to choose that
upbringing you didn't choose the
environment that you grew up in but is
that really who you are
that's not who you are that's stuff that
happened
to this person that's been experiencing
life but you can reinvent and and so
there's a lot of great platitudes and
cliches that are out there but i'm a
performance guy i'm on the field of play
with people all the time that's why i
love your stuff is it's practical and
it's pragmatic right like it has to be
proven under the weight of practical
application and so i hear people saying
you know be your authentic self and be
your best self it's like wonderful
platitudes but what do you even mean
yeah that's because none of these people
have been paid money to coach people
help them develop a best self develop a
more authentic and real version of how
they could actually perform and so for
me the reason i built up my name in pro
sports was i became known as the quick
hit guy
like i'm the guy that you called in when
you were competing at flushing meadows
at the u.s open on saturday and it was
wednesday and you'd been under indexing
all season long and you're in a rut but
i
was happy to take on that moniker wear
that hat because
i came in and i could work with you at
the identity level because the moment
you change someone's identity
everything changes with it while
everyone else is worried about habits
and behaviors wonderful tools to have of
course of course but if you want to
change fast
and if you want to make a change
permanent change someone's identity
because the way that you associate with
yourself
is how the world associates with you
habit number five change your thermostat
setting with ed mylett
change the thoughts beliefs concepts and
value we hold to our self
we will cool or heat our life back to
that regulated temperature and so i'm
telling you the overall key to changing
the external conditions of your life is
changing that internal thermostat
setting so that's what we're going to
talk about some strategies on today just
being aware that you need to alter the
thermostat
is a life-changing liberating condition
what you need to be doing is becoming
aware of how important it is that you
adjust this thermostat setting as you
produce better results as you start to
learn new skills and strategies and
tactics
see you can move from an average
business into an extraordinary business
with incredible opportunity
but you will produce the same results
you're getting in the average business
if you don't change that thermostat
setting up to 95 or 100 120 degrees of
what you believe you're worth the
thoughts concepts and beliefs you hold
true to be about yourself so it is the
regulator on our lives and it's the main
thing i work on with my private coaching
with some of the elite performers i work
with in business in athletics
in entertainment and politics is me
working with them on changing that
internal thermostat where we can heat it
higher and higher and higher so that
they can produce the results and the
conditions of their life stay and exceed
those levels all the time in fact in my
own life i'm always working on my
self-confidence i'm working on my
tactics and strategies my ability to
influence right my thoughts all of those
different things but the thing i'm most
obsessed about that i know is going to
get me to the ultimate version of me is
constantly elevating the temperature in
the areas that matter to me adjusting
that thermostat setting higher and
higher and higher and higher so that i
can get those conditions to match it
because it always will you will always
get your thermostat setting always in
your life habit number six keep your
mind healthy with brian tracy i want you
to take a moment to answer uh the
following question
what are you doing today to keep your
brain healthy and active
if you're like most people you are more
than willing to spend hours each week
focusing on developing a strong and
flexible physical body
but fail to devote any time to actively
seeking out ways to improve your mental
fitness
cultivating a keen and active mind is
key to unlocking a more satisfying and
meaningful life in every area
maintaining a healthy mind is essential
for improving your productivity
strengthening your personal and
professional relationships and finally
realizing your best self
building your brain and keeping your
mind healthy is critical
but it doesn't have to be complicated
here are six actionable suggestions that
can help you
get started today
making your mind as sharp as a razor
first read as much positive material as
you can
your brain
craves new ideas and stimulation and
reading is one of the best ways to
explore them
while there are endless topics you can
explore by reading it's necessary to
keep the majority of the material as
positive and inspirational
as possible
you must really enjoy
what you're reading
continuously exposing yourself to
reading material which is pessimistic or
causes you to become agitated like lots
of stuff in the newspapers today will
have an overall negative effect on your
mental state
this means instead of obsessing over
depressing news articles pick up an
inspiring biography or a non-fiction
book in your field of interest
next exercise
study after study has proven that there
is a direct correlation between physical
exercise and mental well-being
exercise can help to reduce stress and
alleviate feelings of depression along
with boosting positivity aiding
self-esteem and even improving cognitive
thinking
the good news that even moderate aerobic
exercises like walking or jogging or
swimming can have a tremendous effect on
the way you feel mentally
all it takes is 30 minutes of exercises
a couple of times a week to start to see
results
if you can't squeeze a full 30 minutes
of exercise into your schedule don't
worry about it even doing aerobic
exercises for as little as 10 minutes at
a time
is really beneficial
next practice affirmations
by using affirmations on a daily basis
you can counteract some of the
overwhelming negativity in the world
around you and
create a more optimistic outlook for
yourself
your subconscious mind makes everything
you say and do fit a pattern consistent
with your self-concept your master
program
research has shown that through the
simple act of making positive statements
about yourself to yourself you can
reprogram your brain to overcome
unhealthy habits and increase your
productivity and control harmful
emotions
you can find many affirmations online
but the most powerful ones are those you
create by yourself
think of an area of your life
that you would like to change and then
choose an achievable outcome that you
want to reach
frame your desired outcome in a short
present tense statement and repeat it to
yourself throughout the day
let me give you a couple of examples
the most powerful affirmation of all is
the affirmation
i like myself
i like myself
i like myself i learned that fully 40
years ago and i was just
remarkable i was shocked i never heard
it before and the instructor had
everybody in the room say it and today i
have everybody in my room say it all
over the world in now
50 or 60 languages i like myself i like
myself i like myself because the more
you like yourself the more you like
everyone around you the more you like
your work the more you like your
activities the more open-minded and
optimistic you are
try it
another one that you can say is i'm the
best
i'm the best i'm the best
i always tell my children that they're
the best and soon they start to say to
themselves i'm the best i'm really good
perhaps the best of all
is i can do it i can do it i can do
anything i put my mind to i'm not afraid
of anything i can do anything i put my
mind to and finally
which i really love is the words i love
my work
i love my work i like myself and i love
my work get yourself pumped almost like
mental exercise get the blood moving i
like myself i love my work i like myself
i love my work and you'll be astonished
at how much better you feel and how much
better you do your work just
give it a try
my rule throughout my career
has been that you only need to try one
of my recommendations once to find out
if it works or not you don't have to
practice for six months just do it once
and you'll experience
the change and then you'll start to do
it over and over again because once you
experience the change you will be
motivated to do it again
my first instructor in personal
development said with affirmations your
future is unlimited
i never forgot those words i wrote them
down and i rewrote them and i read them
and reread them with affirmations
talking to yourself in a positive way
your future
is unlimited
develop good habits are your habits
holding you back and causing you to feel
bad about yourself or are your habits
pushing you forward and causing you to
feel great about yourself
almost everyone has at least one bad
habit that he or she wishes that he or
she could quit
whether it's procrastination or
self-doubt or the propensity to blame
others when things go wrong or badly
harmful practices are a significant
drain
on your mental health
despite the negative impact of these
self-destructive habits overcoming them
can often be a real struggle
one method many successful people use
or find helpful is replacing a bad habit
with a good habit
so instead of just committing to stop
fearing rejection in social situations
work on developing an exceedingly
gregarious and outgoing personality by
setting goals and working every day
toward them an important point about
setting goals is this is when you set a
goal and you start working toward it
not only do you feel like a winner when
you achieve the goal which you will do
if you don't give up but you feel like a
winner every step of the way you feel
happy and positive and good about
yourself
every step of the way fifth eat healthy
foods
maintaining a healthy mind necessitates
having a healthy diet and lifestyle
throw out the junk food in the cupboard
and stick to eating real foods
many people experience positive mental
health when they eliminate saturated
fats and sugar from their diet
finally set goals with deadlines and
work towards them
this is my favorite of all
standing still not making any progress
is almost worse than
failing when you do start off at least
if you tried to meet the challenge and
failed you probably learn something
valuable about yourself
whenever you make a mistake of any kind
simply ask yourself what can i learn
from this experience what can i learn
that will help myself to be better in
the future keep your mind focused on the
positive part of what you just did and
the negative part will just kind of
disappear
the fear of failure is the biggest
single enemy of personal success for you
or me or anyone else
it's often petrifying enough to
cause you to avoid completing projects
or even having the confidence to start
one in the first place
a positive way of overcoming this mental
self paralysis is to create
smart goals
a smart goal is a goal that is specific
measurable
achievable
relevant and time-bounded
if you have a long-term project
use what is called the checklist
manifesto you take the long-term project
and you break it down into a list of
smaller easier to finish tasks
you organize the list by what you do
first what you do second what you do
third and then you begin
on number one
once you break out all the tasks you
need to do to complete a project
identify the most important tasks
and start on those
make sure that you set deadlines for
each task as well as for the completion
of the entire project or goal
your mental health is critical to
leading the life that you deserve
start making the changes that you need
to improve it today inhabit number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is become truly productive
with jay shetty if i want to be
productive and effective these are the
six habits that i don't negotiate with
no matter what
the first thing i do in the morning is
avoid looking at my phone now it wasn't
always that way the first thing i used
to do was reach over open up my whatsapp
my emails my social media my news feed
and get lost in the notifications the
noise and potentially the negativity
that it brought with it at one point i
used to lock my phone and my laptop and
all my other devices in my car outside
just to get out of this habit i had
bought myself a real alarm clock which i
used to use and that was the way i
trained myself out of grabbing my phone
first in the morning now one of my
favorite things that i do now
is that i have this little post-it note
that i keep next to my bedside table
and on it it says
what are you grateful for
and that message starts my day with a
different thought studies have shown
that when you're present in gratitude
you can't be anywhere else
so when you're having a grateful thought
you can't have an anxious thought when
you're having a grateful thought you
can't have a negative thought and so
it's so powerful to start your day so
grab a post-it grab a sharpie and write
a question on it that you want to answer
first thing in the morning
now you'll be able to tell that i like
post-its because as i brush my teeth i
have this post-it and i got into the
habit of this when i lived this monk
where i put it in front of me
and on it it says i am awareness this is
one of my favorite affirmations to start
the day with i recommend this to clients
to people i'm working with because when
you start with that mindset
you disassociate and disconnect
with the thought of i am the body or i
am my mind and if you think about it we
always say my mind and my body and
spiritual teaching suggests that we are
actually awareness consciousness and so
that reminder at the beginning of the
day
sets me up to now look at my life as an
observer to look at interactions as an
observer to approach relationships from
that slightly
distant view so that i can actually
approach them with the love compassion
the empathy that naturally comes from
the consciousness post-its are great
different colors are great go crazy and
use post-its anywhere in your home to
remind you of powerful mindset [ __ ] a
few years ago i started to realize that
my favorite thing to do in every day was
to learn but when my days got busy with
multiple podcast recordings multiple
meetings zoom meetings phone calls the
first thing that went out of the window
was learning because it becomes harder
to spend time with the book it becomes
more difficult to listen to a podcast
and i'm sure some of you agree with this
or many of you have had this experience
and that was until i discovered blinkist
what i love about blinkist as an app is
that it condenses over 4 000 non-fiction
books into 15 minute reads so i can
browse so many different topics and as
you can see from this i'm pretty much
interested in everything it has to offer
it's it's awesome to have this breadth
and depth in one place
and it makes it so simple to synthesize
the book into these blinks so i can read
or focus on a particular chapter it
gives me a key takeaway and message that
i can focus on and think about
throughout the day and i don't feel that
any day is wasted without that feeling
of curiosity intrigue and learning
tiknot han is one of my favorite authors
and this book the art of living is one
of my favorites so this app allows me to
revisit books that i love it allows me
to extract the key messages and the
essence that i want to apply into my
life and that's often what i'm looking
for is what's an idea that i can read
and take from a book and actually try
and put into practice and live that day
this app has been a game changer for me
in my day and i'm so grateful to be
partnering with them because it's
allowed me to make sure i'm always
learning whether i'm in the back of an
uber a car
whether i'm in an elevator whether i'm
walking around throughout the day it's a
great way for me to always be learning
the next habit has a lot of different
conflicting views and i know everyone
has their opinions about this but for me
personally it's been a habit that has
changed the way i feel
it's
the controversial celery juice now i was
introduced to the idea of celery juice
from multiple podcast interviews i did
and articles i read and i started the
practice to hopefully
allow me to reduce inflammation and
better my gut health and for me since i
started doing this in january 2020 it's
been an incredibly helpful practice i
feel a sense of lightness i feel more
vibrant i feel cleansed every time i
have my juice
and it's been a game changer it truly
truly has so if i'm tired in a day if
i'm feeling that afternoon lull
if i'm feeling a bit
de-energized i know that having a celery
juice is a healthy way of feeling
reinvigorated now it's something that
you i recommend you try and give a go
because it could be a game changer for
you as well
journaling can often be seen as a habit
that wastes time you're sitting there
writing when you could be doing
something but i find setting your
intention and setting your desire for
the day
is a much more powerful and practical
way to now walk into your day and feel
like you know why you're there
to feel a sense of purpose and so for me
setting an intention before a big
meeting before a difficult phone call
before an awkward conversation reminds
me of who i want to be
in that interaction
and that remembrance that confidence and
clarity around who i want to be allows
me to navigate those seemingly difficult
awkward moments that naturally arise
throughout the day so this is a time
that i take and as you can see from my
notes none of these are beautiful none
of these are perfect none of these are
fully aligned they are scattered
spontaneous sometimes random thoughts
and i allow myself to doodle squiggle
whatever it takes because that allows me
to feel that it's free-flowing stop
trying to make it perfect stop trying to
make it look amazing just make it the
way it allows you to feel like you have
a window into your mind and so when i
look at these notes i sometimes think
i'm just allowing myself to express
what's on my mind right now
when i'm having a productive effective
day that doesn't mean i don't get
distracted i get distracted plenty of
times i have tons of notifications
social media big announcements things
that are happening throughout the day
plus a team across the world in
different time zones to manage so when i
get distracted i've created a really
healthy
relationship with distraction i feel
like sometimes our relationship with
distraction is quite negative we see it
as a bad thing we judge ourselves for
feeling distracted we start saying oh i
wish i was more focused or i wish i was
more affected so i literally got one of
these distraction timers as i call it
and i turn it over as soon as i get
distracted i let the sand run out and as
soon as it runs out i have to get back
to my task this gives me the space and
the time to allow for little
distractions and now i figured out a way
to allow myself five minutes of
distraction time every hour so every
hour i allow myself to browse on my
phone for two to five minutes and that
way i know that that time is going to
happen that time is going to come and
that allows me to delay it to put it off
and to postpone my own distractions
you have the power to control your world
how you think how you act your mindset
with the words that you speak when you
use weak language you signal to yourself
that you are weak you signal to yourself
that your goals aren't important you
signal to yourself that you are not
worth it you lose respect for yourself
and the people around you don't respect
you either we need to stop using weak
language and pay attention to the words
that you're speaking to others and to
yourself now this is not an easy task
because most of the words that you're
using the way that you talk to others
into yourself you're on autopilot you're
on cruise control it just happens you've
been doing this for years or decades and
so switching it is not going to happen
overnight but if you pay attention to
the next three things that i'm going to
share with you it can have a dramatic
impact on your self-confidence and the
goals that you have for yourself and on
the outcomes you create for yourself and
the world let's do it number one i can't
i'm not i don't what you say after those
three things shapes your identity it
speaks to how you think and speak about
yourself
so i can't i can't be an entrepreneur i
can't be a leader i can't be a youtuber
i can't i can't i can't i can't i can't
especially this one when you say i can't
pay very very very very very very close
attention to what follows and try
and try and try to shift it from i can't
to either i choose not to or i can't yet
i'm not
i'm not a good salesperson i'm not funny
i'm not the kind of person who follows
through again pay close attention and
try to shift it to not yet
i don't
i don't program i don't know how to make
money i don't think like that
switch i don't do i don't yet i can't
i'm not i don't those statements are
final those statements don't allow for
growth those statements are how you feel
about yourself and don't allow for the
stretch they don't allow you to get
better and so either eliminate them from
your vocabulary or change them to yet
number two is catch your cruise control
the way that you have been speaking
about yourself the way that you have
been talking to yourself has been
happening using the same words for years
maybe even decades it's so automatic for
you you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control and listen don't be too
hard on yourself this is so ingrained
these patterns have been around for so
long you are just auto defaulting to
cruise control that most of these times
you will not even catch it you will not
catch 99
of these moments of these words of these
languages that you're using for yourself
but if you have the awareness if they
have the intention if you have the
desire every now and then you will catch
it another quick hack is to enlist a
friend and list the people around you
your wife your husband your team your
kids kids especially my son hayden loves
calling me out on things enlist their
help tell them this is where i want to
play a bigger game this is where i'm
frustrated with myself this is where i
keep talking badly about myself and
putting myself down these are the words
the language that i need to change and
every time you hear me talking this way
i need you to bring it to my awareness
and let me know because i want to catch
my cruise control for me personally it's
around complaining anytime i complain i
want my wife i want my team i want my
son i want the people around me to say
evan you are complaining right there
that was a complaint eat it right i'm
happy for them to hug me with it to yell
at me with it i just want them to let me
know now when i told everybody they said
listen you barely complain you're like
the least complaining person that we
know
awesome thank you i'm humbled but i
still complain and i probably complain a
lot and a lot of the times i'm missing
it and so please please please please
please please please even if you think
i'm great at it if you catch me
complaining i want you to call me out on
it so enlisting your friends can be
really helpful because you will likely
not catch most of them yourself but it's
imperative that you start working on
catching your cruise control step number
three is manual override you have caught
your cruise control you have found the
autopilot it's about to happen again
this negative talk that you're about to
speak out into the world about yourself
or your ideas you putting yourself down
is about to come out again or has just
come out what do you do about it because
this is really important
if you catch yourself playing smaller
talking negatively about yourself if you
catch it
and you don't do anything it actually
makes it worse
it's better that you don't even catch it
at all
if you catch it and you recognize i am
playing small right now
and you ignore it and you don't change
your behavior you are building that
identity for yourself that you are
somebody who is playing small
you are consciously building that
identity for yourself and you need to
stop it
it makes it worse
where when you do catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it
what do you do you need to kick your
manual override into action and take the
action that you want because that starts
building the positive habit that starts
building the positive respect this is
how you build respect for yourself this
is how you start building the muscle
this isn't just a zero-sum game this
isn't just we go back to neutral
when you catch it you either go sliding
down or you go propelling up
the choice is yours when you catch
yourself playing small when you catch
yourself coming off for cruise control
you have to do the thing
that builds the self-respect up and
speak positively about yourself and do
the thing that you are scared to do
treat yourself
like you're someone that you care about
i read this
this
piece of work by jung a long while back
and it was a meditation on
um the injunction to treat
your neighbor as as you would like to be
treated something like that and what
jung pointed out which i really liked
was that that wasn't an injunction to be
nice to other people
it was an invitation to reciprocity it
was something like this it's like
you should figure out how you would like
to be treated
like you were taking care of yourself
not how you would like people to respond
to you it's more important than that
it's like imagine you had a child that
you really cared for
and and someone said well
people will treat this child exactly
like you want them to but you have to
figure out what that is and so then
you'd have to sit down for like a month
and you'd think okay well how do you
want your child to be treated you don't
want everyone just to be nice to him you
know you want people to challenge him
and you want people to discipline him
and you want people to tell him when
he's wrong it's like you don't just want
everyone to be nice that's that's
pathetic it's pathetic isn't there's no
challenge in that and so
well you want to treat other people like
you would like to be treated well then
you have to figure out how would you
like to be treated
and while you'd like people to fawn all
over you and just lay everything at your
feet it's like no
that's that's not something you'd wish
for for someone that you were taking
care of
and then then there's an additional
problem which is it's often the case
that people will treat other people
better than they treat themselves that
happens extremely
frequently so one of the things i
pointed out chapter two was that
if you have a dog and you take him to a
vet and the vet gives you your
prescription medicine you'll go buy the
medicine and you will give it to the dog
and you will do it properly but if you
go yourself to a doctor and you get a
prescription there's one that there's a
30 chance you won't even pick up the
medication and if you do there's a 50
chance that you won't administer it to
yourself properly
and so i really thought about that when
i first came across that statistic it
really it was another one of those
little facts i thought what the hell's
up with that it's like you'll do it for
your dog so obviously you'll do it for
something you care about and you're
conscientious enough so you'll actually
do it so like
why wouldn't you do it for you your dog
likes you you know even your dog would
rather that you did but but you don't
you don't and and it's actually one of
the reasons that modern medicine doesn't
work nearly as well as it could because
people just don't take their medication
you make the world a much better place a
much worse place if you don't take care
of yourself
so you should bloody well take care of
yourself you know because
well that's what the chapter is about
it's partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world
that's the thing about being an
individual it's the thing that western
civilization has always recognized that
as an individual you have a light that
you have to bring into the world and
that if you don't bring it into the
world the world is a dimmer place and
that's a bad thing because when the
world is a dim place it can get very
very very dark
and so it's not just so that you feel
better and not just so that you're a
number one lobster not none of those
things you need to take care of yourself
because you're in the best position to
do that and it's necessary for you to
take care of yourself despite the fact
that
we're mortal and vulnerable and
self-conscious and capable not only
capable of doing terrible things but
actually do them despite all that
you you're still you still have that
responsibility i get a lot of questions
about how to start meditating keeping in
mind that i had a
a very severe allergy to the word and
concept of meditation for a very long
time more than a decade and i've only
really consistently started meditating
and
implemented meditating for the last two
to three years and this is why i think
meditation can be
viewed
in a way as
stoic training or in some way similar to
cbt cognitive behavioral therapy
because the
objective is to help you to observe your
state and your thoughts
so that you are less controlled by them
what does this mean i'll use an analogy
that i think was originally shared with
me by andy puticombe
who is the founder of something called
headspace which i'll talk about in a
second
which is the difference in effect being
say
standing out in the storm
getting pelted with rain and hail and
wind and stinging your eyes and so on
being soaking wet or
standing inside looking through the
glass at the storm the latter is
meditation
the way i've put it before which is
slightly different it's the difference
between being in the washing machine
or standing outside looking into the
washing machine and when you have that
somewhat detached observer perspective
you can just be much calmer
much more appreciative and ultimately
effective i do not think that meditation
causes you to lose your edge this was a
concern of mine and i think it's a
concern of a lot of type a driven people
but even if it did cause you to lose say
10 percent
who cares
ultimately you're trying to succeed and
make more money do all these things
build a bigger business
to improve the quality of life
for yourself or others and you achieve
that i think more directly
in many cases by
even if you had to take say a 10 haircut
on your edge by improving your present
state awareness by
uh
much much more 50 to 100 so let's jump
into a couple of options
right so if you're not a dog because
dogs are always present stay aware
then you need some human tools one
option and this is the way i started
very early on meditating
was listening to one song so find one
song that puts you into a good mood and
in the morning all you're going to do is
sit comfortably so this could be sitting
in a chair
feet on the floor
just like this
hands in your lap
you generally are going to want some
type of back support
uh you do not need a dog chewing on a
squeaky toy um so i may intervene molly
come here
or hold on there we go
or you can sit like this
which is
uh how i tend to sit when i meditate so
this is not full lotus this is half
lotus it's not even half lotus it's
really just one foot tucked into the
crease of my calf and thigh and then i'm
going to kind of
pull the butt cheeks so that i have a
nice little seat here back flat and then
my hands are either going to be in my
lap like so or i will actually post my
hands on my thighs like this which can
also help if you have a tendency of
slouching to keep your back straight
all right listen to one song for me it
was uh we're gonna party like it's 1999
prince it's hard to be uh stressed out
worrying about things if you listen to
that song trust me
you can pick whatever poison
you like but this was shared with me by
kamal ravikant
and
he suggested listening to one song
doing nothing in particular other than
listening to the song and breathing and
that's three to four minutes that's it
so you can try that in the morning in my
experience people who try to be perfect
are the unhappiest people in the world
and they're almost always the loneliest
too
when you try to be perfect you have
entered a race
that you can't win
you can't even complete it there is no
finishing line the finishing line keeps
moving so when you're in a race to be
thinner
happier richer more successful you can't
complete that race you can't win it and
instead of thinking oh i'm reaching my
goals you feel intense
dissatisfaction here's the truth the way
you feel about everything is down to the
pictures you make in your head and the
words you say to yourself and guess what
is so great you can change those
pictures any time you can change those
words every thought you think
every word you say
becomes a blueprint that your mind body
and psyche use everything at their
disposal to make real
thoughts are things what you speak and
think and say without realizing your
mind is working so hard to make that
your reality even if it's super negative
you know i see parents all the time who
say things like i'll be happy when my
kid sleeps through the night i'd be
happy with my kids out of diapers i'll
be happy when my kid is walking feeding
themselves going to school and they
spend their whole child's life looking
at the next bit to be happy when you
should be thinking wow
i wish every stage took three times as
long you waste your amazing life wishing
it away for the next bit because
happiness is not a destination you
arrive at it's the journey you're on
it's an inside job do not farm out i'll
be happy when
because there is no terminal to get to
good happiness happiness is the journey
you're on now perfectionists come in all
shapes and sizes and they're often very
good at hiding their inner drive to be
perfect there's one thing that drives
them all and in a belief that says i'm
not enough i'm less than if i'm less
than and i can come across as perfect
i'll be more than you know my neighbors
always say to me wow you have so many
famous clients are they damaged by fame
i'm like no actually no
damaged people are attracted to fame
they have a belief i'm so damaged but if
i'm famous rich or just amazing i'll be
perfect could you see what happens when
damaged people try to be perfect it
actually damages them more you don't
need to be perfect you don't need to be
flawless you don't need to be infallible
you just need to be enough and when you
let the fact in that you are enough
sort of trying so hard to be perfect
which you can never achieve when you let
in being enough
changes your life so let it in that
you're enough right now because that's
the truth about you have you ever
thought of
failing
your way to success
think about that for a moment do you
know that anyone that enjoys any kind of
success feels their way there
that's right they do
i want you to think of this for a moment
see this little light here
someone gave me this as a gift this is a
replica
of the light that
edison built
and you know he spent a long time before
he got this thing to glow he really did
and
[Music]
he started off because he had an image
of it in his mind that every time he
tried he failed
and he failed 3
000 times it's been said no i've never
really talked to edison so i don't know
if that's accurate but i have an idea it
is
3 000 failures now a reporter asked him
one time how he felt about failing three
thousand times he said i didn't fail
three thousand times
he's there with three thousand steps to
get to where i'm going
you know if i were to tell you
all the sad stories about
it's got me to where i am
i would really spoil your week and
there's been some real sad stories
i think it might even make me cry again
but i've had so many failures that i
wouldn't even want to guess at it
i have i've blown everything i had three
different times
i never let it bother me much and you
know i have found that
every time i failed i moved closer to
the goal
you see if you knew how to do it now
you'd be going sideways when you're
going after a goal you're going ahead
and because you're going where you've
never been you're going to make mistakes
you don't know it all you have
perfection within you and the objective
of life is to
bring that perfection to the surface
that's exactly what this guy
did well
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
bringing that to the surface
those mistakes
are steps to where you're going
i often tell sales people that are
afraid to make a call
just to get out there and make a call
and their objective isn't to sell their
objective is just make the call
if you make the call and you're afraid
and you do it
you're successful you've accomplished
what you want to do you made a call
and after you get comfortable making
those calls then you can start to polish
up your presentation
and odds are pretty good you'll start
making sales
and if you keep polishing up your
presentation and working at getting
better you're going to master
a thing called selling
but if you think
that you're going to enjoy great success
and it's just one win after another
you're kidding yourself it just doesn't
happen i don't even know anyone that's
pulled that kind of a deal off
if they did they were cheating or lying
i changed my body radically and i do
three things to make sure that my brain
is primed and what i mean by primed is
most people think their thoughts are
their thoughts louis and you and i know
better because you and i have read the
studies right priming is a psychological
principle where
you think thoughts you think they're
yours but very often they're created by
the environment so one example was
harvard has done multiple studies on
this so one of the studies they did
was taking people walking up to people
they hired two actors they walked up to
a hundred people they had to do the
exact same thing men and women
and what they did is they'd walk up with
a cup of coffee in their hand and they'd
look at you and go here we do all this
for a second and look down and reach in
their pocket to pull out their phone
and most people then take the coffee
there's nobody there you're not looking
to give it back right
and then they do what they're doing the
phone they put it back in they go thank
you so much and they take their coffee
back and they walk away
but then about 20 minutes later if
you're in a mall or school campus or
whatever a person comes by with a
clipboard and they give you 20 and they
say listen i know this sounds crazy but
if you'll give me 30 seconds of your
time the 20 is yours i need you to read
two minutes of this literally this
little story and then just answer three
questions for me
here's the interesting part
half the people have a reaction more
than 80 and half have a reaction 80
percent difference and here's the
question they read the same story
but half the people are handed hot
coffee
half the people handed iced coffee
and the question they ask is how would
you describe the main character of the
story after they read a few paragraphs
and the people who are handed hot coffee
say the person is warm and genuine
81 of the people
79 to 80 79.8 it's almost it's a one
percent difference you know natural
variability who are given the iced
coffee say the person is cold and
uncaring i can tell you 20 studies like
that that would blow your mind how your
brain is conditioned or primed by the
environment and think about all that's
gone on with covert of the last two
years and how many people's brains live
in fear and my new health book i put in
there just to remind people with covid
outside being 80 years old the number
one or having four or five comorbidities
number one factor eighty percent of
people die of cove at seventy nine point
eight percent
are obese that's something you can do
something about the second factor
according to the cdc is fear
because anxiety makes people get short
of breath they freak out and their whole
nervous system starts to go shut down
your immune system can be shut down just
by fear alone
and so this experience of life that we
have most people
just don't understand that you are being
primed all the time and unless you prime
yourself you're going to be primed by
the environment which most people
understand that your brain right now is
being conditioned and triggered whether
you know it or not if you're in any
social network it's being done
continuously
by algorithms so i want to take control
of my brain so i do three quick things
one
i take three minutes of those ten
minutes after i've changed my body and i
focus on three different events in my
life that i'm grateful for i usually
pick two big ones and one small one it
could be as simple as a smile on my
daughter's face
the wind against you know my skin but i
really i don't like if you ever been on
a roller coaster and you remember the
roller coaster over there it's not the
same as remember going over the edge
like you're there so i do it in an
associated way and it changes your
biochemistry now it sounds pretty you
know positive thinking i'm going to be
grateful
but there's a value to it because the
two emotions that mess up your business
your life your relationships are anger
and fear
and you can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously
and you can't be fearful and grateful
simultaneously so by starting my day
with that and it's not some fake pump up
positive thinking the real experiences
so it literally teaches your body to go
in that state because otherwise the
environment when right now there's a
whole lot of uncertainty and fear then
real fast i do this three-minute process
that's kind of like a blessing and then
three minutes the last three minutes are
called three to thrive where i focus on
three things i want to accomplish but
instead of thinking i want to accomplish
i see feel and experience it is done i
feel grateful i celebrate it
and it trains your brain so in 10
minutes i'm done third thing that i'll
do i immediately send a message or a
text or an audio message to somebody
as a sincere compliment and i don't go
dude great job or wow you're cool i say
listen i saw you on tuesday with those
kids and i saw you take that extra 20
minutes no one else did i just want you
know i saw that i thought that was
incredible so i'm always very specific
so they know it's not just some positive
thinking [ __ ] call it's sincerely
doing it it makes me constantly look for
the good in the people i work with
fourth thing i do is whatever i don't
want to do the most challenging part of
the day i want to go handle that problem
i want to handle that issue because
after you do that everything has
momentum so those four are my court you
must come up with a morning routine
that you do
every single morning or at least more
mornings than not
that puts you in control of yourself
and in control of your day
this is what i do and i cannot explain
the power that i get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses and being in
control
first and foremost wake up on time when
that alarm goes off get your butt out of
bed five four three two one go
why is that important for persistence
the reason why is because the first
decision that you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving
that means you are
persistently
bigger than your excuses you are
persistently bigger than feeling lazy
and you are persistently beating the
feelings that typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email
before you answer your phone before you
start surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed
and you know team stream and checking
out the sales on zappos and looking at
your facebook news feed before you pick
up the damn phone
please please please
figure out your two priorities for the
day
these are the things that matter to you
whether it's saving money and and making
sure you're focused on that or showing
up at work and being a contributor or
whether it's changing how you treat your
spouse or your kids or the person that
you're with or heck getting to the gym
because you said you would whatever it
is that your two priorities are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why
the reason why
is because of persistence the reason why
is because i want you to have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day
is
snoozing
starting your day off late starting your
day off tired starting your day off by
mainlining everybody else's news feed on
social media and looking at everybody
else's life and and saying to yourself
oh my god they're on vacation or gosh
they look so great or their friends are
so fancy or my gosh they've got some
money
you start off your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day you
gotta start off your day by getting up
on time figuring out your priorities and
then getting to work on them do not pick
up your phone until you have done those
two things i think the single biggest
reason why people have bad days is
because they start them off by looking
around at everybody else and seeing what
they're doing instead of having the
focus and the discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center so you want a bonus
round exercise every day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise you do those
three things you'll be kicking ass every
single day
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag
in the comments below on this video i
will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to change your life in 20 minutes
with tony robbins check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there so today we're going to learn from
tony robbins and examine some of his
best motivational clips that he posted
in 2016 as an incentive for you to go
for your best
this year mentor me tony clip number one